hi guys this is anjali from simply learn
and today we look into the tutorial on
the configuration management tool puppet
so before we start one thing I'd like to
mention is that puppet falls on the off
site of the DevOps approach so let's
begin so what will we learn today today
you'll learn about why we should use
puppet
what exactly is puppet the puppet
architecture how puppet works and
finally we'll have a demo on the
installation of Apache on our own so
let's begin
why puppet so consider the scenario of
an MNC the MNC puts together the small
team of system administrators they are
responsible for taking care of the
infrastructure of this organization now
this infrastructure could consist of
data centers server centers and many
such components fortunately for the MNC
they were doing extremely well so the
number of clients kept growing
consistently and with this came a boom
in the infrastructure size now here is
where the problem came in with such a
large infrastructure the small team that
they put together in no way could manage
this so what do we do the solution seems
pretty simple right just increase the
size of the team shop we'll increase the
size of team but when do you think we
can put an upper limit on the size when
do we get to stabilize this team so here
is where puppet comes in with puppet a
small team is enough to take care of
this large infrastructure this is
because the data center server centers
all of them can be updated in a matter
of seconds with puppet entire load of
doing so has now shifted from the team
on to the tool not only this with puppet
if servers do fail and there's a very
high chance of servers failing when you
are considering an organization the
scale of an MNC puppet can instantly
roll them back to the previous working
steps and if that wasn't enough puppet
also provides a capability to deploy
servers on demand and enforce security
on them now all of this is done through
simple coding which is written in Ruby
we look at how puppet works more so now
that we know why we should use puppet
let's have a look at what
sadly is public so first and foremost
puppet is a configuration management
tool as I already mentioned in the
beginning of this video so this simply
means that puppet ensures that all your
systems are maintained at a consistent
state so consider that you want to
deploy a number of servers now you
require these servers to be identical if
this task is given to a human there's a
very good chance that those systems will
not be identical or some of them may
even fail human are prone to errors you
cannot blame them
so puppet ensures that all these servers
are deployed on time and they are
identical secondly puppet is also a
deployment tool this simply means that
puppet has the capability to deploy your
applications your services software's
all of this on your nodes automatically
and finally puppet implements
infrastructure as code now this term
infrastructure as code is a very
important one when it comes to the
DevOps approach you would have noticed
this term being used in a previous video
on chef - if not you can always click
the top right corner to know more so
what is this term infrastructure as code
mean infrastructure as code simply means
that all your policies your tasks your
instructions everything is written and
coded format so in case of puppet
specifically all of this is written in
the Ruby language so now that we know
what puppet is let's look into the
puppet architecture so puppet has a
master/slave architecture as you can see
here on the top we have the puppet
master and below we have the puppet
clients so the puppet master is the
system where your system administrator
sets the Clyde's are those systems which
require configuration you can have n
number of clients connected to the
puppet master so don't worry we look
into each of these components in detail
firstly we have the puppet master
so the puppet master is where the system
administrator sits and he or she types
in the codes here so the codes are not
only written in the system but they are
also stored here and whenever the client
requires these codes for their
configuration they simply request it so
manifest is the first sub competent of
the puppet master these are the actual
is where the codes are written so in
case of puppet these are Ruby files
modules die manifest templates and files
into a single unit
now these codes dictate the instructions
for performing various tasks on your
client the next component is templates
so if manifests are your code templates
are the data so let me explain this to
you with an example consider you want to
create a file called index dot HTML on
one of your client machines so what you
do is you write the code for creating
this file in your manifest and the
content of this file is written in your
templates then you simply link them but
here's the thing when you divide your
code and data in this way it's a very
clean structure so it's preferred to do
it in this manner files is static
content so the files are basically sent
to your client and they simply
downloaded at the client there is no
execution all compliation involved with
your files now this is where files and
templates are extremely different
because with template they are never
sent over to your client the templates
are simply read by the parser at the
master itself
modules dies the Manifest templates and
files into a single unit so modules is
not a separate component as such it just
provides a very clean hierarchy this is
the most important component of the
puppetmaster CF which stands for
certificate authority now as we will see
later in this video the puppet master
and the puppet client communicate
through an exchange of SSL certificates
so when the client sends over the
certificate to the master CA provides
the master the authority to sign these
certificates the minute the master signs
a certificate the master is basically
saying that yes this client is
registered with me and I agreed to
exchange data with this Kline an
x-component puppet client of course
these are the systems that require to be
configured agent is a service installed
on the client the agent is solely
responsible for all the communication
between the master and the client and
finally we have factor so factor is
responsible for collecting all the data
about the present state of our client
and sending the data over to the
but master at the master this data is
compared against the manifest which are
your code files and then these manifests
are sent over to the client depending
upon the results of this comparison so
now that we had a look at the various
components of puppet let's see how these
work together so we have a master and we
have three clients now before any
information can be transferred between
the master and the client it's important
that these components recognize each
other also there needs to be an
encrypted channel of communication
between each pair of Master and client
now all the data which is transferred
between the master and the client it
flows through this channel so let's see
how this entire procedure of recognizing
each other works the core of this
procedure are the SSL Certificates SSL
stands for secure socket layer secure
socket layer is a security protocol and
it forms an encrypted channel between
two components what this encrypted
channel ensures is that all the data
that is passed through this channel is
not accessible by any other system
outside so it provides complete security
ok so we will consider a very general
scenario we have a master and a client
here this is not the puppet master or
the puppet Klein they're just two
systems and we are just going forward
with master slave architecture so the
client so far is not a client it is just
a system and we will refer to the system
a system a so system a sends over a
client certificate to the master
associated with this client certificate
is the hostname of system a now master
goes through the certificate it's easy
hostname and then it decides whether it
wants to form a communication link with
the system aim if it does it signs the
certificate and the signed certificate
is sent back to system e now the system
a is officially at aligned the minute
the master signed the client certificate
it said that yes I am willing to
exchange information with this system
and I do take the system as one of my
clients so now that the system is
official your client it can request for
data from the master and the Master will
simply send over the data now we are
here to talk about puppet so
if this was a puppet master and this was
a puppet client then the first three
stages will be the same so the puppet
client sends over the certificate to the
master the master science a certificate
sends it back and the client requests
for data now by data here of course we
mean the configuration data those are
the manifest or even could be your files
so what happens after this request after
this request the factor service which is
present on your clients collects all the
information regarding the present state
of your client so this information could
include the operating system that
installed on them the various number of
software present on them the versions of
the software
now all this information is collected
it's called the fat and it's sent over
to the master ad the master this
information that is the fax is compared
against the manifest so why does the
master do this the master basically
compares the facts against manifest to
know if what the manifest is about to
perform is already performed on these
systems so if the manifest has some
additional functionality they are
compiled into catalogs and then these
catalogs are sent over to the client now
remember those agent services which
existed in your clients here's where
they come in the agents take the catalog
and execute them on the client once
executed these catalogs make the
required changes on the client and a
report is generated this report is then
sent back to the master so the master
keeps record of all the changes that's
made in the system and this comes very
handy when one of the system's failed
and it's required to be rolled back to
its previous working state so this
entire procedure can be repeated in
number of times and can be repeated at
regular intervals so if you have a
scenario where a system needs to be
configured every 30 minutes what you can
do is you can set your interval and
automatically every 30 minutes your
systems will be configured and we reach
the final and the most exciting part of
our video which is the hands-on so today
I'll be showing you how you can use
puppet to install Apache on one of your
client machines so we'll be using two
machines here we'll have a
and we'll have an ode machine the server
is essentially a master the node is your
client I'm just using the term server
and node instead because I want to keep
it very close to as their use in the
commands now both these machines are
going to be sent to as seven machines
and I have Oracle VM VirtualBox
installed on my machine so on that I've
simply created two virtual boxes both
sent to a seven of course so before we
move on to the actual demo I'll just
take you through the various steps so
first we'll install the puppet server on
our server or master machine will then
start the server service we then shift
over to our node or the client machine
and we'll install the puppet agent
service we will then start the service
tube and the minute you start the puppet
agent service an SSL certificate is
created so this certificate will have
the hostname of your note attached to it
and this is how the master or the server
will recognize a certificate and then
it'll sign this certificate so once your
master or the server signs the
certificate you can write your manifests
so the manifest has just the codes for
configuration and once that two is done
you shift back to your client or the
node system and you run the agent
service so once you run the agent
service your manifest or your cat logs
because as you know the manifests are
compiled into catalogs these are
executed on your node and this will make
the required changes so that's how this
entire process is going to work now
let's move on to the actual demo this is
my Oracle VM VirtualBox manager the last
two machines you see here are the ones
we'll be using for this demo the puppet
server is your puppet master puppet
client of course is the client so let's
just have a look at these two machines
this is my puppet server so just so you
can differentiate guys the terminals
have been set accordingly puppet server
has a black background with white text
and puppet client here has a black
background with green text so we'll move
on to server machine or the masked
machine cuz that's the one we'll be
working on first so before we begin we
need to set the hostname
of a master to puppet so this is a very
essential step in the configuration of
puppet if you miss this out there are
quite a lot of other changes you'll have
to make in certain files so let's do
this first so that's the command to set
the horse name the last word you see
there that's the new host name you want
ok so now we'll just check if a horse
name is set so just type host name and
yeah it's puppet so next we will check
the IP of this machine so for that you
just type if config enter so this is
your IP guys under a and p0 s 3 in its
value that is 192 point one sixty eight
point two point 183 of course the IP
will differ for you guys
needless to say so note that down
somewhere cuz we will require it when we
are configuring our client ok so now you
want your puppet server and your client
to communicate so for this we need to
remove certain firewalls so the command
for this is sudo because we want the
root permission system CTL stop firewall
D and put in the password
okay so all your firewalls are removed
so the next step now we start on with a
puppet process so we download the puppet
labs at first now guys ensure that your
systems your virtual boxes in this case
are connected to the net also you won't
be getting an IP if it's not for the
first time so here's a command to
download the puppet lab enter the
password again okay so the puppet labs
is downloaded now you need to install
this so installation guys we will be
installing the puppet server on the
master machine or the puppet server
machine
so this may take a while
you
so that took a while so I just skip to
the last part where it's completed the
installation process is over now we need
to make a small change in our system
config puppet server file so let's just
move to the file first
this file will open in VI editor
so this line here it basically allocates
memory for your puppet server now you do
not need to GB so we are going to reduce
the size
512 MB should be enough so guys notice
here I did not type the B okay so I just
changed this to X M s 512 m let's save
that
always remember to open this file using
sudo otherwise saving the changes you
made could be quite troublesome okay so
now we can start a puppet server service
we enable the service okay so that's
done so basically a puppet server
service has started it's running
pleasantly so for a while we are done
with the server machine let's move on to
our client machine okay first things
first
we open our EDC host file with sudo cuz
you need to make a few changes and save
it open this in the VI terminal
okay guys so here you have to add this
one line at the end type in the IP for
your puppet server machine puppet puppet
- master so let's say if this file
now we'll move on to downloading puppet
labs on a puppet client so the command
is the same that we use for puppet
server
so puppet labs is downloaded now we need
to install the puppet agent service here
again this will also take some time
puppet servers installed let me just
clear this window now that a puppet
agent service is installed we'll start
the service so I'll just type in the
command for starting the puppet agent
service as you can see here and
short-changed
stop to running so basically the service
was not running before and now it's
changed to the running State
and while we executed this command not
only did the service start running but
an SSL certificate was also created so
the certificate should have the hostname
of this machine that's a perfect line
machine attached to it so let's just
check what the hostname of her machine
is that's localhost dot local domain so
our certificate should have this
attached to it so guys the first time
your client sends a certificate the name
of the certificate itself is usually the
host name of the machine so our
certificates name should be localhost
dot local domain we'll check this on our
master system and that's where we will
sign the certificate to
so first we list out all the
certificates in our case since you have
just one client and we just started the
client we should have technically just
one certificate and it will be so yeah
so this is a certificate localhost dot
local domain we now sign the certificate
okay sorry about that just need to
remove these brackets
yeah as you can see her the certificate
is signed signed certificate request
here so once the certificate is signed
the request for signing the certificate
is removed that's this line now that a
certificate is signed we can begin to
write a manifest so let's move into a
manifest folder and we'll create a
placeholder file
so we'll create a file called sample dot
PP this is a sample file we won't be
writing anything in this file as of now
so we are just checking here we're just
creating this file and then we'll go to
our client machine and just check this
if we can access this file from there so
now we will move to a client machine
so let's test the connection
so as you can see here it is applied cat
lock in 0.03 seconds so our catalog is
executed on a client machine
now a catalog was just a placeholder
basically so the file that we created
which is sampled or PP had no content
and we were just testing outlined now
let's go back to our master server put
some content into this file and see how
the execution takes place so we'll open
our file sample dot PP which we created
earlier in the VI editor let's type a
code here so node and then within the
brackets we enter the hostname of a
client machine so this ensures that our
manifest is executed on this particular
machine now the Apache service package
on CentOS is called the httpd so this
line that I just typed in is the action
it will ensure that the httpd package is
installed on your client and that's it
so this is our code we'll save it now
let's go back to a client machine and
test it
so the supply machine
and our catalogs applied on the klein so
I just clear the screen now we will
start the Apache service okay so how do
we see if it's running we just need to
go to a browser
and at localhost you must have the
testing page for your Apache
so we type localhost enter and yeah this
is the testing page for Apache so as you
can see we have successfully used puppet
to install the Apache service on a
puppet line and this is the end of our
demo and with that we also come to an
end of our video so let's go through
everything we learn today at first we
looked at why we should use puppet then
what exactly is puppet we had a look at
the puppet architecture and then how
these components work together to
provide the puppet capability we also
saw the exchange of SSL certification
and finally we had demo on installation
of Apache on one of our clients using
puppet hope you all found this video
informative and it answered all your
questions regarding puppet if so please
hit the like button also subscribe to
our channel if you haven't yet
this is anjali signing off thank you hi
there if you like this video subscribe
to the simple learn youtube channel and
click here to watch similar videos to
nerd up and get certified click here